welcome to the show everybody feeling
feeling pretty good today personally my
my Baltimore Ravens demolished the Rams
last night I'm on at football don't know
if you watch that and you know I was
thinking last night as I was watching as
I was watching it all unfold on top of
everything else I love how the the
Ravens are named after an Edgar Allan
Poe poem because Poe lived in Baltimore
died in Baltimore he also married his 13
year old cousin in Baltimore which we
don't really talk about that part of it
that that part we leave to the side but
the point is that bottom the Baltimore
Raven refers obviously to the poem The
Raven which is why they're mascots the
rate of mascots are named Edgar Allan
Poe so it's very subtle and I remember
when rave the Ravens came to Baltimore
in 1995 and when we stole the team from
Cleveland which was fine because our
team had been stolen from by
Indianapolis in the 80s and so we turned
around and stole our team from Cleveland
and you know fair's fair if you if you
get your something stolen you could
steal from the next person that's the
way it goes in America and in anyway so
there was a poll a vote to see you know
what we would name the new team and
everybody in this city was voting and I
think as a kid at the time I wanted
something like the Dragons you know
something fierce like the Dragons or the
butcher's the Baltimore butchers that
would be good but the nerds wanted a
19th century literary reference and they
won and and I was mad at the time but I
appreciate it now because now that I'm
older and I'm a nerd myself I really
appreciate the literary reference every
time I watched football great stuff okay
speaking of nerds Pete Budaj he's a nerd
which which I mean as a compliment smart
guy obviously Rhodes Scholar I don't
know if you heard about the fact that
he's a Rhodes scholar and so we're only
reminded of that every time he does a
debate but probably the most talented
politician the Democrats have right now
and that I don't that's not that's half
a compliment in half an insult I think
he's wrong about everything I also think
that he's cynical and manipulative
especially in how he slanders Christians
while pretending to be one so I'm not a
fan of his by any stretch of the
imagination but he is smart and he's
good at what he does as a political
candidate but he was trending on Twitter
this morning in a not so positive way in
fact the phrase Pete Buddha judge is a
lying MF was trending and that's about
as bad of a trend as you can get I think
as a as a political candidate that's the
title of an article in the route and
it's an article that just blasts away at
Buddha judge calling him a lying mother
blank basically painting him as nothing
more than a lucky privileged spoiled
lying brat essentially and taking issue
and this of course is from the left this
is an attack on him from the left taking
issue mainly was something that he said
about about something he said about
eight years ago while he was running for
mayor of South Bend and he was talking
about disadvantaged kids and the
education system and anyway they taking
issue with with what he said and take a
listen to it right here you know the
kids need to see evidence that education
is gonna work for them right so you see
a lot of parts that's part of the
motivation yeah because you're motivated
because you you believe that at the end
of your educational process there is a
reward there's a stable life there's a
job and there are a lot of kids
especially the lower income minority
neighborhoods who literally just haven't
seen it work there isn't somebody they
know personally and I think those who
testifies to this value of education so
yeah you bet that's what this writer at
the root is mad about and that's what
makes them a lying MF bunch of leftists
are also mad it seems now the question
is
wrong with what he said
far be it for me to defend Buddha judge
but What did he say that was wrong there
what where's what's the wrong part of
that well this guy at the root says that
it's it's the problem is not about bad
role models despite what Buddha judge
claims it's not a lack of Rotem role
models
it's about minority neighborhoods being
neglected underfunded schools in the
inner city being underfunded and racism
in all of these external circumstances
you see and the thing with Buddha judges
he just got lucky and that's why he's
been successful and so for him this just
sit there in judgment he's racist and
wrong and it's deceptive but of course
that's all nonsense
the big advantage that but a judge had
is that he had a mother and father
growing up okay that is a big advantage
that's not luck though it's gonna that's
that's not a roll of the dice the mother
and father chose decided to be present
that's a choice they made it's not luck
the point is that in the inner city
you're talking about 70 or 80 percent of
the kids don't have a dad in the picture
70 or 80 percent
now of course that's going to have an
enormous impact of course that's going
to mean a dearth of male role models
especially for boys who have a special
need for male role models in their lives
they need a man to show them how to be a
man and it's it's much easier and better
and more effective if you have that
example in your life that you could look
to okay it's kind of the the show Don't
Tell thing as you could tell kids all
day long this is how you're supposed to
act but you need someone there to show
you how to act someone that they can
emulate now so - this is all really
obvious and to deny it is madness it's
not bad luck father is abandoning their
families are not unlucky okay unless
they died but if if they're still alive
and they've abandoned their families
they chose to do that they chose not to
be there for their kids were Thor in
prison or something they chose to commit
a crime it's not luck
it's a choice made by those fathers so
you've got a huge amount amount of men
in the inner city who conceive children
and then don't stick around to raise
them that is a statistical reality the
article says just reading a little bit
from this article in the route it says
it proves men like him but a judge are
more willing to perpetuate the fantastic
narrative of negro neighborhoods being
moneda more role models and briefcase
carriers then make the people in power
stare into the Sun and see the blinding
light of racism get along moderates
would rather make crap up out of whole
cloth than wade into the waters of
reality Pete Buddha judge doesn't want
to change anything he just wants to be
something this is not just a lie of
omission is a dangerous precedent this
is why institutional inequality persists
not because of white hoods and racial
slurs it is because this insidious
double-talk erases the problem by
camouflaging it because it is painted as
a problem of black lethargy and not
Wight apathy he say these making stuff
up he's making crap up actually said
he's making s up what is he making up
what okay here's the question is the
fatherless rate very high in the
inner-city or not yes or no answers yes
unless we're gonna say 70 percent isn't
very high another question are kids
without fathers at a huge disadvantage
and do they lack essential male
leadership and as an essential male role
model in their life the answers yes
question do men who conceive children
and then not stick around to raise them
make that choice because of racism is is
it racism that prevents them from
raising their own kids answers no so
where is Budaj is wrong you know I don't
have a dog in this fight I'm not a I'm
not a fan like a set of Buddha judge but
the truth is the truth
and this is a truth that we need to be
able to talk about
when it comes to the fatherless problem
by the way it's not just a problem in
the black community it is it is a it's
it's a problem and I'll have the numbers
right in front of me but if you were
talking about especially in the inner
city like I said seventy or eighty
percent even in in in white
neighborhoods in the suburbs it's not
that high but it's a lot higher than it
should be so this is a problem across
the board in America I would say this is
a cultural problem shared across the
board to one degree or another is a Mac
a lack of male leadership in the home
and a lack of the influence of fathers
listen every time most of the times when
we've had a school shooting a mass
shooting this is one of the things that
some of us talk about that I talked
about
and very often the kids who do that are
white but you know what else you find
very often is that those kids didn't
have dads in the home not in every case
but in many of them in most of them
so obviously we need to talk about that
and to insist that we focus the
conversation entirely around these sort
of external environmental things racism
and all of that and we make people the
victim of their own choices and when I
say that I'm not referring to the kids
in the inner city who grew up without a
dad they're not a victim of their own
choice they're a victim of the choice
their father made and when you read
articles like this it sounds like we're
trying to take those fathers who abandon
their children and make those father's
victims of their own choice of
abandoning their families and that's
just that's just wrong
now politically this shows why the
Democrats I think might be doomed
they're they're they're tearing their
most talented candidates apart nobody's
allowed to rise to the top of the pack
without being ripped to shreds the sjw's
have this purity test that nobody can
pass even a young gay man like Buddha
judge can't pass it Camilla Harris a
black woman can't pass it Elizabeth
Warren a female socialists can't pass it
who can pass it nobody can pass it so
they all get eaten alive by their own
people and Trump just sits back and
enjoys the show so it's working out for
really well for Trump I agree with what
Tucker Carlson said I think last night
where he said that he still wouldn't
count Michelle Obama out and I think
that that is their only hope and I
wouldn't count her out either
I think Michelle Obama on the left is
basically untouchable or the closest
thing to untouchable among leftists that
you can get probably the one person in
the whole country who could unite all of
these disparate warring factions on the
Left you're not gonna see any Michelle
Obama is a lying MF articles about her
that's that level of disrespect and that
kind of attack is reserved for people
like Buddha judge you're not gonna see
that Michelle Obama there's a reverence
that they all all the left has seemed to
have for her she also has a some appeal
in the middle as well so I think she'd
be a formidable general election
candidate I think that's maybe their
only hope right
I just don't see anyone else obviously
someone's getting nominated among the
Democrats but they're all gonna come
into the general election extremely
wounded after all the slings and arrows
they've taken from their own side and
that works again to Trump's advantage
okay speaking of people getting attacked
for speaking basic facts I have another
example of that that I want to share but
first a word from field of greens have
you ever wondered why so many Americans
are sick unhealthy and overweight
between the food supply and sedentary
lifestyle Americans are in the worst
shape they've ever been and I'm sure
you've seen all the news reports about
that it's a well known problem well
let's not talk about problems let's talk
about solutions that's where the team of
on staff positions at brickHouse
Nutrition come in and that's where they
created field of greens fill of greens
is an easy way for you to add fruits and
vegetables to your daily routine without
spending hours in the produce section or
hiring a home chef or taking cheap
supplements that's that's either stuff
you don't have time for or can't afford
well fear to field of greens is made
with real USDA organic fruits and
vegetables it also helps boost your
immunity using antioxidants and assist
in digestive health health with
prebiotics and probiotics it's like
having a doctor nutritionist right in
your kitchen one scoop delivers a full
serving of fruits and vegetables just
dropping it a cup of water stir it and
you're done you can make a smoothie
that's how I recently that's why I've
been been having it you know make a
smoothie very healthy very good easy to
make great stuff bottom line this is
real food not extracts you will look
better you'll feel better go to brick
house Walsh dot-com get 50% off your
first order just for trying it up with
promo code Walsh that's brick house
Walsh dot-com promo code Walsh okay so
as I said speaking of the left war on
facts journalists and II know he's best
known for his run-ins with an Tifa he's
the guy that got assaulted sent to the
hospital
with a brain injury by auntie pho a few
months ago something that by the way
Democrat candidates still have not
condemned that's a real attack on the
press on a journalist hasn't been
condemned media
condemn it Democrats in commitment well
he is now suspended by Twitter for
relaying in objective fact and and
relaying it in a in an objective and
dispassionate way he shared some
verifiable statistic statistical
information and for that he was banned
now it started with a tweet from Chelsea
Clinton Chelsea Clinton tweeted since
2013 more than 150 trans people have
been murdered in the US the majority
black transgender women on t dor 2019 i
guess it straight trans this is a trans
day of remembrance they call it we
remember and honor to honor the lives
lost hold their loved ones in our hearts
and must commit to doing all we can to
end this epidemic of violence and hate
now Clinton is connecting this with hate
obviously insinuating claiming that
these are all or mostly hate crimes
throwing in the black transgender woman
detail mentioning the race also tries to
turn it racial so the idea is to make it
seem like there are a bunch of racist
transphobes out there murdering black
quote trans women left and right now and
Ino responded saying and this is what
got him banned or at least suspended the
u.s. is one of the safest countries for
trans people the murder rate of trans
victims is actually lower than that for
the Syst population also who is behind
the murders mostly black men that's it
that's what he said got suspended for
that suspended
responding to an inaccurate claim with
some verifiable empirical facts so what
Twitter is saying is we support this
false narrative and if you try to debunk
it we're gonna punish you you're not
allowed to debunk it it's it doesn't
matter if it's not true you're this this
is what we're going with but the fact
remains they could suspend you for
saying it but the fact is the fact as I
talked about a few weeks ago sharing a
piece from chad felix green over at the
federalists the anti trans hate crime
epidemic is a fiction it is a myth it's
been made up its invented it's not real
the vast majority of trans murder
victims are not the victims of a hate
crime the vast majority of trans murders
have nothing at all to do with bigotry
or anything like that they've mostly
been the kinds of murders that you find
in the non trans population
murdered in the same kinds of
circumstances for the same reasons it's
sad it's terrible it but it's not a hate
crime
also a sizable number of murder victims
among trans people are people who live a
high-risk lifestyle so prostitutes and
that sort of thing the murder rate among
prostitutes generally trans or not is
higher than the average population but
that's not because of anti prostitute
hate crimes that's it's because you're
living a high-risk lifestyle you're
living in in a world where in it in a
dangerous world you're dealing with
dangerous people you're doing a
dangerous thing
that's not victim blaming that's not
saying they deserve it obviously because
nobody does it's just pointing out that
this is there's no connection here with
racism and hatred
the what's driving this is something
completely separate from that
now or it may be hate anyway but it's
not maybe you could make the argument
that any time somebody's killed its
there's hatred behind it which i think
is actually probably not true I think
more very often I think what lies behind
murders and other crimes as a sort of
indifference to human life less than
than a hatred for human life
but either way
just the fact that's all none of this is
to say that the murder rate among trans
people or black people or any group
doesn't matter actually I'm saying the
opposite I'm saying let's deal with
what's actually happening what look
let's deal with the reality because only
if we deal with the reality is there a
chance of making a difference
it's the people who use murder victims
like political props who obviously lack
empathy and lack compassion when you're
doing that when you're taking trans
people have been murdered
and you're turning them into a political
weapon to bludgeon your opponents with
then you're the one who lacks compassion
for them
and we're not going to be able to solve
the problem call it an epidemic if you
want it's it's not really but whatever
you want to call it we're not going to
be able to solve the problem if we
insist on diagnosing it incorrectly it's
a very basic thing if you want to solve
a problem whether we're talking a
societal problem or a medical problem or
any kind of problem you have to diagnose
it correctly to begin with
and so I think what a Nino was trying to
say what I'm saying
but a lot of us have been telling us
let's diagnose this problem correctly
and then we could talk about solving but
Twitter says no it's better to it's
better to diagnose it incorrectly in
fact we insist that you do
all right let's move on to emails
because there's a few topics brought up
in the emails that I wanted to spend a
little bit of time on Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
this is from Jake says hey Matt quick
talking point for tomorrow's show as I
am sure you saw Bezos donated 98.5
million dollars to charity Jeff Bezos
and that still was not enough I saw some
comments going around that if you make
fifty thousand dollars that will be the
equivalent of donating forty five
dollars
my point is I doubt all the people
complaining have ever donated that forty
five dollars to any cause it is easy to
virt you signal and demand more social
programs when it when it's when it is
someone else's hard earned money big fan
of the show keep up the good work
god bless ya Jake I saw that Bezos
donated as you said 98 million dollars
and people were attacking him for it
which is amazing and if if you want to
diagnose this problem I really think a
lot of it is garden-variety jealousy
that's what a lot of it is
people clinging desperately to their
narrative of the greedy rich person to
have a rich person who also acts
generously interferes with the narrative
and so they find a way to dismiss it
that it's also I think that people are
upset that they themselves are not
billionaires and they look at Jeff Bezos
and their main problem with Jeff Bezos
is that they are not Jeff Bezos they
want to be him that's that's what you
have to understand all this attacking of
billionaires most of the people doing
the attacking their main issue with
billionaires is that they themselves are
not billionaires that's what they don't
like about billionaires is that they're
not in that population up so I think and
this is this is unfortunately human
nature a lot of people do that we all do
this in in some way or another to some
degree or another where you know you see
someone who's got something you want and
their life seems to be working for them
well
and you feel jealous you're envious and
so you want to tell yourself that
there's something wrong with them and
that's what people do I think a lot of
these socialists and everything these
would be faux socialists they look at
rich people and really in their heart
they want to be rich but they're not
and so instead they tell themselves oh
well you know these are all bunch of
greedy these are all a bunch of greedy
bastards and at least I'm not like that
at least I'm a better person they might
have more money than me but I'm a better
more virtuous person and then when you
see that the billionaire isn't greedy
and they're donating a lot of money and
doing a lot of good in the community now
they're thinking wait a second is this
person richer than me and better that
can't be
they can't be richer and more generous I
can't allow that to be the case and I
agree with you all these people saying
oh Bezos giving 98 million dollars is
like me giving 50 well first of all no
it isn't because I'm pretty sure the
charity would prefer the 98 million to
the 50
okay it makes a difference to them there
are practical things that 98 million
dollars can do that $50 cannot now if
all you have to give us 50 and you give
the 50 it's like the parable that Jesus
told the woman that just gave you know
put two coins into the you know at the
synagogue rather than the the rich
people that made a show of giving more
so yes in terms of the the the moral act
itself the moral significance if you
give less and that's all you can give
it's a great thing and it does make a
difference but it obviously practically
speaking 98 million dollars that's going
to help a lot of hungry and homeless
people whereas fifty dollars will help a
lot less so in a practical sense it's
not as good but also I agree with you in
that all these people saying well it's
like if I gave fifty are you giving
fifty though
if you are great but I kind of doubt
that you are
these people complaining about rich
people all the time and greedy and
everything every time they see
philanthropy among rich people they find
a way of dismissing it all these people
that Clinton it's say oh you know I
that's not as generous as I can be
well are you generous are you actually
giving your money to charity
I tend to doubt it I think a lot of
these people are hoarding their own
money and that's what really gets them
is that they know in their hearts that
even though there are a lot more than
someone like Jeff Bezos than a
billionaire they have a lot less money
they're actually more greedy
that's the thing if you're making you
know seventy thousand dollars a year or
something and you give none of it to
charity and you don't help anybody with
it
um and meanwhile you've got a
billionaire giving millions the
billionaires more generous than you and
yet you could say he's got more money to
spend but you're giving nothing you're
not doing anything I mean you could
spare some of that if the 70 thousand is
not 70 billion but it's it's there still
you still have some room like maybe a
few of the coffee's you bite Starbucks
maybe maybe don't get that iPhone
upgrade you know maybe you already have
Netflix you don't need Amazon too you
could sacrifice some of that and give to
the less fortunate but you don't because
you're actually more materialistic and
greedier than some of those rich people
and I think that's what really gets them
they hate to think that oh my gosh am I
am I not only broke but greedy too
nobody wants to think that about
themselves all right
that's one thing I've talked about
before you see
consumeristic culture coupe
consumeristic isn't really a word but
let's go with it
what you find is that
even people who are not rich like me and
you assuming you're not rich who's over
watching this a lot of us have sort of
inherited the vices of the rich
because living in this consumerist
culture even people who aren't rich can
tend to be materialistic greedy just
hoarding goods and things for themselves
and so a lot of us we have the vices of
the rich we have the greed of the
materialism we don't actually have the
riches of the rich and so we've got the
worst of all the worlds okay this is
from Murray says I'm a young mom of two
little toddlers and my two and a half
year old is really pumped for Santa to
come this year I've told her the true
meaning of Christmas and it basically
made Santa help her for Jesus emphasis
on helpers so she'll still get the point
I've never thought of not giving her the
fantasy of Santa until talking with a
friend recently the friend said that her
parents made Santa very real with noises
on the roof jingle bells and everything
so when she found out that all that hope
and joyful anticipation was complete
nonsense she was devastated
she still is devastated and refuses to
tell her kids about Santa I've had a few
friends experience something similar it
makes me sad what have you done for your
kids are you ever worried about the day
that they inevitably discover the
fantasy of Santa Claus I'm at a
crossroads of what to do because both
pose their pros and cons I'd love your
opinion you're a great dad thank you for
all your talk for all you talk about I'm
so disappointing the sexualized
obsession of the young and our culture
never stop speaking you make such a
difference god bless you and your family
yeah Marie first of all I would say
about your friend it seems like their
parents went way overboard but if she's
still devastated that Santa Claus isn't
real
it might be time for her to get over
that one you know we all went through
that as kids and it was a little
difficult at first but probably by the
time you're an adult you should be over
I don't know I know maybe you can't say
that to her maybe you should just say to
her just put it flat out next time she's
complaining about the fact that Santa
Claus doesn't exist maybe say to her
listen yeah you know that you're like 30
right but in terms of what to tell your
kids here's the way that I look at it
and I brought this point out many times
before when talking about gender issues
and kids choosing their own gender and
everything my point is that very young
kids you say you're toddlers okay two
and a half years old well a two and a
half year old has no idea what reality
is is no concept of reality doesn't know
the difference between fiction and and
truth and fiction so if you were to say
to your two and a half year old Santa
Claus is not real that wouldn't mean
anything anyway
so my point is you you couldn't convince
a two-and-a-half-year-old that there is
no such thing as Santa Claus because a
phrase like there's no such thing as
just doesn't mean anything for them they
don't have the cognitive ability to
understand that and so that's why
children naturally live in a fantasy
world you're two and a half year old if
you have a three-year-old a
four-year-old
they also probably think that spider-man
exists and Superman exists and they
watch Bugs Bunny you know they think
that that's real they watch cartoons I
think it's real it's not because you've
told them that you haven't gone out of
your way to convince nobody goes out of
their way really to convince a
four-year-old that Spiderman exists but
if they see spider-man on TV if they
watch a movie they're gonna think that's
real because the whole idea that you
could be watching something an image but
it's not real it's just that's there's a
disconnect there because they think well
what do you mean it's not real I can see
it of course it's real so I wouldn't
worry about it I guess is what I'm
saying if
kids are young enough we're believing in
Santa is appropriate then they're also
so young that you couldn't convince them
anyway that Santa Claus doesn't real so
you might as in real so you might as
well just go with it and as they get
older and they're capable of
understanding that there is this thing
there is a reality which set which is
set apart in some way from fantasy as
they get older when they get to be you
know five six seven they start to
understand that then they're getting to
the age maybe where I think you break
the news but also at they're also
getting to the age where they're gonna
they're gonna start figuring that out
anyway in fact for me with Santa Claus I
actually I actually did not have the
devastating moment where my parents sat
me down and gave me the bad news I kind
of just figured it out on on my own
because I had older siblings and they'd
stop believing and so just over time
you're just kind of like oh okay hold on
a second you start piecing it together
so if you talk if you told your kid if
you told your kid nothing at all about
Santa Claus you didn't you didn't saves
real or fake or anything you just didn't
say anything about it I think your child
at a young age would naturally believe
in Santa Claus because he would pick it
up from his friends and from the culture
and from TV and everything and then you
know around six seven eight would stop
believing and that would happen apart
from you completely so all you're doing
as a parent is maybe
hurrying it along a little bit or you
know kind of guiding them one way or
another a little bit but kids are gonna
live in that fantasy world and there's
also nothing wrong with that so
if you if you would not I said we don't
we don't go out of our way to convince
our kids that spider-man is real yet
they do believe that spider-man is real
would you would you sit them down and go
out of your way to convince them that
spider-man isn't real what anyone would
any parent do that why your look your
daughter believes that there are fairies
in the garden are you gonna sit her down
and say listen there are no fairies stop
believing in fairies
what kind of crazy parent would do that
no she believes that just let her
believe it now yeah you play along a
little bit and cuz it's fun and she's a
kid she's just who cares all right we'll
do one more this is from Zach says dear
Matt since the Christmas season
essentially starts on Friday please rate
the following five gifts from one to
five five being the worst socks a worn /
used item that's clearly been rege if
today chav lottery tickets a christmas
ornament or a clothing item that is
clearly two sizes too small and comes
with a gift receipt thanks for all you
do and watch the show regular
religiously well I need more
informations act because are you talk
about socks are the socks the fancy
high-end socks that you buy you get a
pair of them for 14 bucks at Target that
for me is fancy and high-end that's not
a bad gift I have no problem with rege
if that items in principle now if you're
saying they've been worn or obviously
used okay if someone's giving me a
blender that still has chunks of
smoothie in it I'm gonna have an issue
with that but we gift it in general I
have no problem with now you talk about
ornaments okay that's definitely a five
that's a twenty really if five is the
worst than twenty it's a twenty it's off
the scales bad ornaments are the worst
gifts we all we've all been guilty of
giving Christmas ornaments as gifts to
other people yet we all know that none
of us want Christmas ornaments as gifts
so we all participate in this thing
where we give a gift that we know we
wouldn't want you know Jesus says
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you well give gifts that you would
want also in some world
nobody wants a Christmas ornament you
give this get a little thing a little
ball or whatever that you hang on a tree
for a few weeks along with all the other
ornaments it just gets lost in the
shuffle who's gonna be excited about
that and the worst thing is this is why
gift-giving stresses me out and and I I
would be in favor of just abolishing all
the gift-giving occasions and just never
giving never giving or receiving any
gifts I'd be fine with it what stresses
me out is you're sitting there on
Christmas morning and you're doing your
family gift unwrapping thing and you get
a gift like an ornament and it's
obviously super lame and you don't care
about it but you have to act excited
because the person who gave it to you
sitting right there even though they
know unless it's a child okay that's an
exception here but if it's an adult they
know that you're not going to be super
psyched about the ornament but they
still expect you to act like you are and
they know you're faking it and so
there's this the psychological
back-and-forth the the mind games that
are being played I don't like it
very bad at faking enthusiasm so I
opened up the ornament knot and I have
to go oh cool that's the best I can do
oh cool is that it in ornament yet
ornament yeah oh yeah this will look
great on the tree this will look great
with 300 other ornaments I'll just put
that in there and I'll forget about it's
great no thank you so much Wow Wow
where'd you get this where'd you you
have to ask a few questions right that's
that's the one way I sell it to try to
distract from the fact that I'm not
excited I'll start asking questions
where'd you get this from me oh you got
it from you got from the mall Wow
what mall oh wow wow look at this
ornament oh my gosh I just woke up this
morning so hoping I get an ornament you
got 600 ornaments I just saw that I was
thinking I need I need another one I
mean I need a 601 ornaments oh thank you
so much for this ornament thank you so
much for it you obviously hate me could
give me a gift that I want
a gift card if that's you you wanted to
spend seven bucks on a gift so just get
seven dollar gift card to just touch a
Starbucks okay that'd be much bag I got
actually use that that's my reaction I
it's it's Christmas morning gets awkward
in my house anyway that's my feeling
about that thanks for the question I
think we'll wrap it up there thanks
everybody for watching Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there